mark is in North Carolina Merry
Christmas mark welcome to the Dave
Ramsey chef Merry Christmas you Dave
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
how can I help I have a question right
now my wife and I are renting and were
paying or having a lot of our stuff in
storage and we'd like to buy a house but
we're going to retire in five years and
so the question is when we retire we
most likely will move and so would like
I just to determine what does better for
us financially to continue to rent or to
buy and then like I said possibly in
five years knowing that we likely move
you know the difference between paying
rent and a mortgage and the down payment
everything else that goes with it yeah
good question well the analysis
mathematically would be based on the how
hot the area that you are in is from a
real estate perspective where do you
live in North Carolina you smell it oh
good market okay good mm-hmm so in the
particular neighborhood that you were
going to live in I would drop a point
there with your real estate agent and
say do it do me a five-mile radius
analysis of this area okay I'm ten mile
I don't care something like that and
you're looking for two statistics from
the Multiple Listing Service from your
real estate agent and you can get one of
our real estate LPS to do this for you
first thing you're looking for is in the
last ten years five years what is the
average annual appreciation rate in that
five or ten mile ring how much of the
house has gone up okay the second thing
you're looking for is do a.m. days on
the market average days on the market so
let's then let me throw you a couple
numbers out there going to run congruent
they're not going to run opposite of
each other meaning that if you see a
high appreciation rate that means that's
a hot market and you're also going to
see a short days on the market
greed right easy to sell a house in an
area that's hot going up in the markets
hot right so if you're going to see a
low appreciation rate you're usually
going to see long days on the market so
if you find a 2% appreciation rate you
might find a 200 day or 270 days nine
month time on the market right days on
the market
don't buy if that's the case because
what you got is you got 2% a year for
five years it's a 10% increase your
commission off the backside will be six
plus other expenses and you're gonna sit
there nine months trying to liquidate
the stupid thing that's not gonna work
agreed no but if you find that markets
hot like the county I live in gee nuts
okay white hot and so I mean you might
find average days on the market be seven
days and you might find a 7%
appreciation rate well seven times five
is a 35 percent increase in value during
the five years not counting compounding
and and and so if I pay 10% out and
expenses I still make twenty five
percent and so I live there for free and
made money and I don't want to do that
one if I was gonna be there five years
so if you're gonna live in my County
you'd want it I don't know that that's
the exact numbers of my County but if
you're really have in my County which is
hot as a firecracker you you'd want to
buy for five years but if you're in an
area where the markets a little more
sluggish you know you might not even
break even and you might might be
sitting on a stupid thing you can't get
rid of it off the back side of the five
years so that's how you do the analysis
and if it's kind of in the middle and
you just don't care then I'd probably
rent okay
yeah because that's the concern is to
put down the twenty percent and and you
know twenty percent back and some on
that if the markets going up agreed
right right so I'm not worried about
getting a down payment back but don't
worry about when you get it back how
hard is the house to sell and the do am
is gonna really tell you that days on
the market in that particular area that
you would want to buy in and of course
what's that going to be associated with
it's going to be associated by the
quality of the neighborhood the quality
the school
system it's gonna be associated by
reasonable traffic patterns and shopping
and access to restaurants and things to
do and economic activity and these are
where people want to live right and it's
known as a good neighborhood in air
quotes right a good neighborhood and so
you'll see that you'll see that show up
in the statistical analysis if you
really want to dig down into it you can
kind of get a gut feel for that just by
walking around in the area I mean you
just you live there you kind of know and
you hear stories from your neighbors
like oh my god that house sold so fast
or you can't give a house away right now
you know you hear these things right and
so that's what you really want to get
into and figure that out my guess is in
Charlotte if you're in a reasonably good
area of Charlotte that you will make
plenty of money in five years to buy
that's my guess but check it and run the
numbers and you'll see what you find
Charlotte's very similar to Nashville in
size and demographics not quite as hot a
city as Nashville is right now and the
neighborhood I live in is not Nashville
I live in a county south of Nashville
and Franklin which is twice as long as
Nashville and national is pretty crazy
but anyway charts good market there's
nothing wrong with it's not a dead
market it's not it's not in the doldrums
it ought to be you ought to make enough
in five years to buy there unless you
just go into a bad corner over there
somewhere